primetime inside the trump
investigations live tonight at
nine. Just in to CNN. Disturbing
new video showing detainees
locked behind Gates and a
migrant center in Mexico as a
deadly fire broke out. The blaze
killed at least 40 people and
was apparently started by
migrants during a protest. CNN's
Rafael Romo has our report. One
by one Mexican soldiers pull
people out of the building, it
quickly becomes tragically clear
. There's nothing they can do
for some of them anymore,
Mexican officials say. Died at
this detention center after a
fire swift through the building
late Monday surveillance video
from inside the detention center
obtained by CNN shows how
quickly the flames spread
throughout the holding area
after inmates said mattresses on
fire. It also appears to show
that those detained were behind
bars with the gate locked.
Informal algo movie, calling the
fire regrettable and sad.
Mexican president Andres Manuel
Lopez obrador said the fire
started Monday at 9 30 in the
evening hours before, officials
say 71 migrants living on the
streets of ciudad Juarez had
been taken to the shelter is to
the president added that the
fire started after the migrants
found out they were going to be
deported as a protest, the
president said the migrants put
mattresses from the shelter
against this door and set them
on fire. But they never imagined
this was going to cause this
terrible accident, he said, as
first responders tried to save
victims at the shelter, family
members desperately tried to get
any news from their loved ones
outside the building, and now
they're not telling us anything.
Thing, this woman said, a
relative of yours may die and
they don't tell you anything at
all. We have seen. They've been
pulling people out, and we have
no idea if they're alive or not
, this man said. Ambulances have
left one after the other and we
know nothing and they give us no
information. Located across the
border from El Paso, Texas.
Juarez is a transit point where
many immigrants from different
parts of the world arrived daily
, hoping to cross the Rio grande
to seek asylum in the united
States, as it has been the case
with other border towns in
Mexico. There have been multiple
riots intense situations in the
last few years due to the fact
that there aren't enough
shelters that can accommodate
all of these migrants. And many
end up living on the streets
through a statement. The
Guatemalan government says 28 of
its citizens were among the
dead, irregular migration, the